let's review a little bit of what we had
learned many many videos ago about
gravitational potential energy and then
see if we can draw the analogy which is
actually very strong to electrical
potential energy so what did we know
about gravitational potential energy if
we said this was the surface of the
earth and we don't have to be on earth
but it makes visualization easy we could
be anywhere that has gravity and the
potential energy would be due to the
gravitational field of that particular
mass but let's say where this is the
surface of the earth we learned that if
we have some mass m up here some mass m
and that the gravitational field at this
area or at least the gravitational
acceleration is G or 9.8 meters per
second squared and it is H we could say
I guess meters but you know we could use
any unit let's save is H meters above
the ground that the gravitational
potential energy of this object at that
point is equal to the mass times the
acceleration of gravity times the height
or you could view it as the force of
gravity the magnitude of the force of
gravity it's a vector but we could say
the magnitude of the vector times height
and so what is potential energy well we
know that if something has potential
energy and if nothing stopping and we
just let go that energy well we put with
gravitational potential energy the
object will start accelerating downwards
and a lot of that potential energy and
eventually all of it will be converted
to kinetic energy so potential energy is
energy that is being stored by an object
situation or not or a kind of this
notional energy that an object has by
virtue of where it is so in order for
something to have this notional energy
some energy must have been put into it
and as we learned with gravitational
potential energy you could view
gravitational potential energy as the
work necessary to move an object to that
position now if we're talking about you
know work to move something into that
position or whatever we always have to
think about well move it from where well
when we talk about gravitational
potential energy we're
talking about moving it from the surface
of the earth right and so how much work
is required to move this that same mass
let's say it was here at first to move
it from a height of zero to a height of
H well the whole time the earth or the
force of gravity is going to be F sub G
right so essentially if I'm pulling it
or pushing it upwards I'm going to have
to have and let's say at a constant
velocity I'm going to have to have an
equal and opposite force to its to its
weight to pull it up otherwise it would
accelerate downwards I'd have to do a
little bit more just to get it moving to
accelerate it however much but then once
I get it just accelerating essentially I
would have to apply an upward force
which is equivalent to the downward
force of gravity and I would do it for a
distance of H right what is work work is
just Force Times distance Force Times
distance and it's four it has to be
forced in the direction of the distance
so what's the work necessary to get this
mass up here well the work the work is
equal to the force of gravity times
height so it's equal to the
gravitational potential energy now this
is an interesting thing notice we picked
the reference point as the surface of
the earth but we could have picked any
arbitrary reference point we could have
said well from I don't know 10 meters
below the surface of the earth which
could have been down here or we could
have actually said you know some from a
platform that's 5 meters above the earth
so it actually turns out when you think
of it that way that potential energy of
any form but especially gravitational
potential energy and we'll see
electrical potential energy it's always
in reference to some other point so it's
really a change in potential energy that
matters and I know when we study the
potential energy it seemed like there
was kind of an absolute potential energy
but that's because we always assume that
the potential energy of something is
zero at the surface of the earth and
that we want the know the potential
energy relative to the surface of the
earth so it would be kind of you know
how much work does it take to take
something from the surface of the earth
to that height but really we should be
saying well the potential energy of
gravity like this should
this statement shouldn't be you know
this is just the absolute potential
energy of gravity we should say this is
the potential energy of gravity relative
to the surface of the earth is equal to
the work necessary to move something to
move that same mass from the surface of
the earth to its current position we
could have said you know we could have
defined some other term that is you know
not not really used but we could have
said you know potential energy of
gravity relative to minus five meters
below the surface of the earth and that
would be the work necessary to move
something from minus five meters
to its current to its current height and
of course that might matter what if you
know we cut up a hole and we wanted to
see what what is the kinetic energy here
well then that potential energy would
matter anyway so I just wanted to do
this review of potential energy because
I want because now it'll make the the
jump to electrical potential energy all
that easier because you'll actually see
it's it's pretty much the same thing
it's just the source of the field and
the source of the potential is something
different so electrical potential energy
just just when you know actually we know
that gravitational fields are not
constant we can assume they're constant
maybe near the surface of the earth and
all that but we also know that
electrical fields aren't constant
actually they I have very similar
formulas but just for simplicity of
explaining it let's assume a constant
electric field and if you don't believe
me that one can be constructed you
should watch my my videos that involve a
reasonably bit of calculus that show
that a uniform electric field can be
generated by an infinitely by an
infinite uniformly charged plane and
let's say this is the side view of an
infinitely uniformly sorry an infinite
uniformly charged plane and let's say
that this is its positively charged of
course you can never get a proper side
view of an infinite plane because you
can never kind of cut it because it's
infinite in every direction but let's
say so that this one is and this is the
side view let's so first of all let's
think about its electric field well its
electric field is going to point upward
how do we know it points upward because
the electric field is essentially what
is and this is just a convention
what would a positive charge do in in
the field well if this plate is positive
a positive charge is we're going to want
to get away from it so we know the
electric field points upward and we know
that it's constant that you know if
these were field vectors that they're
going to be the same size no matter how
far away we get from the field let's
form the source of the field and I just
I'm just going to pick a number for the
strength of the field we actually proved
in in in those fancy videos that I made
a on the uniform electric field of an
infinite uniformly charge playing that
we actually proved how you could
calculate it but let's just say that
this electric field is equal to I don't
know 5 Newton's per Coulomb that's
actually quite strong but it makes the
math easy so my question to you is how
much work does it take to take a
positive point charge let me pick a
different color let's say so let's say I
have so let's say this is a starting
position it's a positive I don't know
two coulombs once again that's a massive
point charge but you know where we want
easy numbers how much work does it take
it to to move that to cold Coulomb
charge I don't know three meters within
this field how much work so we're going
to start here and we're going to move it
down towards the plate three meters and
in its ending position is going to be
right here right that's where it's when
it's done how much work does that take
well what is goal what is the force of
the field outlet right here what is the
what is the force exerted on this two
Coulomb charge
well electric field is just force per
charge right so if you want to know the
force of the field at that point let me
do that draw that in a different color
the force of the field acting on it so
let's say the field force or the force
of the field actually is going to be
equal to five Newton's per Coulomb
times two coulombs which is equal to ten
Newtons and we know it's going to be
upward because this is a positive charge
and this is a positively charged
infinite plate so we know this upward
force of 10 Newtons so in order to get
this charge to pull it down or to push
it down here we essentially have to
exert a force of 10 Newton's downwards
right exert a force of 10 Newtons in the
direction of the movement and of course
just like we did with gravity you have
to maybe do a little bit more than that
just to accelerate a little bit just so
you have some net downward force but
once you do you just have to completely
balance the upward force so just for our
purposes you have a 10 Newton force
downward and you apply that force for a
distance of 3 meters the work that you
put to take this 2 Coulomb charge from
here to here is going to be equal to the
work is going to be equal to 10 Newtons
that's the force times 3 meters so the
work is going to equal 30 Newton meters
which is equal to 30 joules and a joule
is just a Newton meter and so we can now
say since it took us 30 joules of energy
to move this charge from here to here
but within this uniform electric field
the potential energy of the charge here
the potential energy of the charge here
relative to the charge being here you
always have to pick a point relative to
where the potential is so the the
electrical potential energy here
relative to here potential energy and
this is electrical enter potential
energy and you could say you know P 2
relative to P 1 I'm using my made-up
notation but that gives you a sense of
what it is is equal to 30 joules and how
could that help us well if we also knew
the mass let's say that this you know
this charge had some mass we would know
that if we let go of this object by the
time it got here that 30 joules would be
essentially assuming it you know not
we've got transmitted to heat or
resistance or whatever we know that all
of it would be kinetic energy at this
point so I actually you know we could
work it out let's say that this does
have a mass of I don't know one kilogram
let's say it has a mass of of one
kilogram and we were to just let go of
it right we were you know we we use some
force to bring it down here and then we
let go so we know that the electric
field is going to accelerate it upwards
right it's going to exert a force of
upward force of five Newton's per
Coulomb and the thing is going to keep
keep e excuse me keep accelerating until
it gets to this point right what's its
velocity going to be at that point well
all of this electrical potential energy
is going to be converted to kinetic
energy so essentially we have 30 joules
is going to be equal to one-half MV
squared right we know the mass I said is
one so we get 60 is equal to V squared
so the velocity is the square root of 60
so it's you know seven point you know
something something something meters per
second so if I just pull that charge
down it has a mass of one one kilogram
and I let go it's just going to
accelerate and be going pretty fast once
against at this point anyway I'm 12
minutes into this video so I will
continue in the next but hopefully that
gives you a sense of what electrical
potential energy is and and and really
it's no different than gravitational
potential energy is just the source of
the field is different see you soon